okay ask a question here in the front
row
that's it um
that was my favorite character though
the horse was your favorite character
i really don't know what to say if the
horse was your favorite character
i'm glad you liked the horse but uh
i thought i created a few characters who
were even more engaging than the horse
you know that surprised me too when i
saw it
because silver is the the silver is
definitely not dead in the in the books
in fact uh
i've was just writing a scene uh the
battle of marine
uh which opens the winds of winter where
uh
uh sir barristan uh danny is is gone
from the city so sebastian
rides to silver into battle to kind of
uh conjure her up so the horse is still
around
uh in in book six in the thing and is
only dead in the in the tv show
i guess they just wanted to show the the
uh crossing the
the uh called the the red waist and how
dangerous it is
on the other hand although they killed
the horse they kept the handmaid alive
you may recall that in the book one of
dany's handmaids dies of thirst and
sickness and dehydration while crossing
the red waste
and that handmaid who was seen in the
background is still alive but you
you'd rather have the horse okay
ah you're one of those people huh
you got to be very careful about killing
animals uh
when we killed uh lady in in the first
season
you know we got hundreds of letters of
protest and
and angry things about people i'll never
watch your show again
um nobody cared that we also killed
micah the butcher's boy
uh the the dog got a lot more uh a lot
more
impassioned defenses than uh
than the poor kid so i don't know what
that tells us about uh people
i can tell you a funny story about the
the horse though if you want a funny
story about the horse
is actually related to uh the original
pilot which we filmed in morocco
as some of you know we did a certain
amount of recasting after the first
pilot so
we filmed danny's wedding scene in
morocco and of course uh there's the big
sequence there where
where danny is uh given the silver
philly by by called rogow and in the
book she
she uh she mounts up the philly and she
she rides away and they they're is she
writing away because she's afraid
she is she's trying to flee and and but
she turns the silver around she rides it
out and she rides it back very fast
through the center to camp
and there's a huge fire in the center of
the camp and she leaps over the fire on
the horse
and we had that stunt all set up to uh
to go i was in morocco as
as doing a cameo as one of the wedding
guests and
was watching them trying to trying to
film that and we had uh
we had this beautiful silver philly and
uh
gorgeous looking horse just magnificent
to look at
um and we had one of europe's top stunt
riders
and we had this great fire built and we
were going to do the whole thing
that horse just would not jump over the
fire there's nothing we could do
they spent uh they spent half the day
trying to get the damn horse to jump
over the damn fire and
it didn't work you know so finally david
and dan said well okay put out the fire
put out the fire and just have the horse
jump over the logs and then we will put
in the fire with cgi
that horse still won't jump over the
fire
says i don't care you're not fooling me
that was on fire a little while ago
and uh i'm too smart to jump over that
so he had to scrap the whole thing which
kind of
was disappointing because it's a it's a
fairly big moment in the book
but uh that's the realities of
television production you can't
you know if you're peter jackson you're
filming water rings you could take three
weeks to get the horse jumping over the
fire but on a television budget
you better get it because otherwise
you're going to fall behind and you're
going to have to cut other stuff so you
got to do it
but then we did the uh the the
wedding consummation uh where
uh danny and drogo right out to
consummate their marriage
now um that was different in the
original pilot than it was in the uh
version that was ultimately broadcast
the original pilot was much closer to
what i wrote in the books
it took place at night it took place by
a stream
and the two of them ride out on their
horses and they they tie their horses to
a nearby tree and it's
it's more of a seduction than the uh
than the rougher
uh consummation semi-rape confirmation
that you see in the uh
in the pilot is filmed so but it's still
a sex scene and
it was cold in morocco too i mean it was
it was hot during the day
it was like 100 degrees during the day
but you're in the middle of the desert
and then at night the sun goes down it
gets very cold so
we're all standing around wrapped up in
blankets and poor uh
uh jason momoa and and uh times and
merchant who was playing danny are
naked uh doing their sex scene and it
was
you know pretty pretty hot sex scene
that we're watching and we're watching
on the video cameras here at night
and uh they're off by the stream doing
it and suddenly i hear
hear someone laughing and then someone
else starts to laugh
and i'm hearing this ripple of laughing
what the hell is going on it's ruining
that
you know they're doing this passionate
lovemaking scene that looks pretty good
to me why are people laughing at it
there's nothing
funny and then i said oh and what we
realized then was the silver philly was
not in fact a philly
uh the silver philly was a stallion
and uh evidently was quite turned on by
the hotness of the
hotness of the sex scene because in the
background we're seeing this enormous
horse erection that is
that is appearing right behind the uh
the actors so uh we had a cut
cut and when we redid it
you'll notice there are no horses in the
background of the scene as
as ultimately filmed so so that maybe
that's why they killed the silver horses
all the trouble that that horse
caused wouldn't jump the fire and uh you
know
getting turned on during the sex scenes
is terrible